RGB hardware is everywhere you can get
everything from RGB graphics cards to
headsets with that said we thought it
would be fun to construct a PC using
nothing but RGB components it adds to
the cost of our build and doesn't
provide any meaningful performance
benefits but hey it scratches our
tron-like itch let's walk you through
our RGB components for a motherboard
we're going with gigabytes g1 gaming x99
fenix sli it supports RGB lighting with
the company's ambient surround LEDs you
can see these spread throughout the
board's PCB and heat sinks we can
control all these lights with gigabytes
appcenter software which allows the leds
to pulsate or even beat to the rhythm of
the in-game sound effects and music for
our glowing graphics card we went with
the ROG Strix GeForce GTX 1060 guard
uses a Seuss's Ora RGB lighting system
and supports a six different lighting
patterns that include breathing strobing
and more not only does the logo light up
but it has a bunch of flashing LEDs
plastered on top of its shroud we're
using intel's 8 core 59 60 X central
processing unit RGB CPUs don't exist but
it doesn't matter since they're tucked
under coolers that's why we went with
NZXT s and X 62 RGB liquid cooler it
uses the company's acam software which
provides a ton of customization options
that allow you to tweak the lights to
breathe fade pulsate and more for our
RAM we went with 16 gigabytes of GL Evo
X which uses the company's hybrid
independent light module technology to
light up the logos and LEDs above the
heat spreaders that even more pizzazz to
our build we incorporated NZXT s Q plus
LED system it offers four LED strips
with 40 lights on each Channel and you
can daisy chain them together with NZXT
scam software you can also program them
to change colors based on your PC's
temperature the supplement our hue plus
lighting system we use NZXT s RGB fans
they come in 120 and 140 millimeter
sizes and can be synced together with
companies camp software to form a
rainbow color rings for RGB power supply
we chose a thermal takes 750 watt tough
power dps gps you as enough juice to
power our light show and it also has a
built in RGB fan that offers 256
for our case we went with be quiet dark
based Pro 900 the full tower chassis
comes with two light strips coupled with
a physical LED switch it also offers a
big tempered glass window which will
properly showcase all of our glowing
innards for our mouse we chose a
Logitech G pro not only does the G logo
glow but it also has a sleek LED ring
around the palm rest that supports up to
sixteen point eight million colors the
supplement our glowing mouse we went
with the razor's of firefly crema the
RGB mouse pad supports sixteen point
eight million colours around the
perimeter of the base for our keyboard
we chose a steel series apex M 800 not
only does the plank support sixteen
point eight million colors but the
company created its own qs1 switches
which mitigates light bleeding that you
normally see on more common back light
Cherry MX keyboards for our gaming
headset we chose a logitech g930 three
Artemis of the spectrum which look like
headphones out of a sci-fi movie with
bright LED lights that run around its
ear cups the headset also supports
sixteen point eight nine colors while
most monitors offer srgb colors through
their displays our lenovo y 27g eraser
edition monitor offers 16.7 million
customizable RGB colors on the back
which create additional mood light
creatives a sound buster executes on a
sandbar is the newest RGB product in our
lineup the speakers use the company's
Aurora reactive lighting system to
deliver a forty nine programmable LED
lights that are aligned from edge to
edge it also offers a sixteen point
eight million colors with our RGB
components out of the way let's put it
all together and light it up
[Music]
at a little over 4 grand our RGB setup
is super expensive in practical and kind
of gimmicky but we still think it's kind
of cool and hey let there be light
so that was our RGB setup if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to us on YouTube
[Music]